how Wild was it that you were so your
persona was faces covered how excited
were people when you revealed your hot
face they're probably expecting some Ugo
feminists and you guys are so hot you're
like psych I was hot the whole
time I mean that must be an extra like
shot to the gut right like really want
to
they explore the benefits of micro doing
THC micro do.com and use code trash
Tuesday to get free shipping and 30% off
your first order again that's micro
do.com code trash Tuesday remember it's
micro do.com and don't forget to apply
code trash Tuesday for your 30% off
discount hi slugs I'm so excited to
announce new shows I added the final
dates of this tour um obviously January
7th rescheduled San Jose and then
January 18th I will be in Portland and
January 26th in Seattle I'm so excited
my favorite cities please um come hang
out and I'll see you get tickets at
Esther and ice.com hi sluggy I am on the
road you can see my next Annie wood and
friend show at The Comedy Store December
21st we got you may know I'm friend of
the show Bobby Le on it um we have a lot
more too I'm going to be in Texas I'm so
excited come see me in Houston December
15th through 17th I'm going to be at the
comic strip in Edmonton January 12th and
13th I'll also be in Jacksonville
Florida in January I'll be in Denver
Colorado in February and Vancouver I'll
also be in DC in March so go to Annie
Annie go to Annie letter.com shows you
guys can edit around that
right just sent Julian over to grab
paper towels for my armpits and maybe
you're my upper lip is good today Annie
your what my upper lip is good today I
wasn't talking about your upper lip are
you talking about my [__]
riding this going to be part of the show
yeah why is this not included Julian
that is included a strong man bringing a
woman some wait can I just say that I've
completely changed my opinion on [__]
size wanting it small is the wrong move
well is yours engorged at this point no
nothing has changed but I just the
videos I watch about giving birth I'm
like the bigger it is the better you are
and it's like a hat for the baby to come
out it's just crazy that keep them warm
it's crazy that for years we're all like
oh we want it to be small like travel
you want short and why yes yes you have
a daughter right correct yeah wait what
I birth in um I gave birth in um 30
minutes no no it was before 30 minutes
on
your no Nadia you are an activist you
are a part of a punk rock Art Collective
called [__] rot that you started mm
when you were 22 I was yeah I think 21
yeah around the 10 my bad oh my God no
at 22 I already got imprisoned so it was
um it was the fast track you have babies
fast and you get arrested fast I like
that you've been arrested multiple times
you spent two years in a Russian prison
you are um part of the most wanted list
in U most wanted criminal in Russia
that's yeah yeah and you do amazing
things everyone Nadia [__] Riot thank
you so much for having me Kila pulled it
together she always
does I'm um I think you're in inedible I
think everything you do is um everything
I've always maybe deep down wanted to do
but never had the courage I always feel
very like oppressed by perception I
always feel very afraid of what people
might think of me or the repercussions
and so you are absolute goals for me
you're you're my hair and makeup goals
if that means anything after that like
for sure exact exact hair and makeup
goals Esther's also going to be like
wearing her outfit next week trying to
play it
off I'm going to tell you what what it
means after 10 minutes will pass because
we cannot say this word just yet wow um
I was watching a 60 Minutes uh piece
about you and they were they kept going
but they're using such foul language
it's like I know so fun like why are you
worried about the language and like they
anytime anyone ever says anything about
what you say it's like they always use
the word a offensive and it's like
really like how thin skinned like how
thin skinned is Putin like how thin
skinned are these people that even just
girls moving around doing their thing
just really really like penetrates like
really gets them going well my theory is
um Putin wants Russia to appear very
homogenous So currently his
biggest um wish I
think um
you know image- Wise for Russia to PR
homogeneous as everyone supports the war
in Ukraine and everyone supports Putin
so sometimes they um fake elections to
the point that they claim that 100 41%
voted for
Putin that's the ultimate goal what an
absurd this is the reason why even if
one person steps out of the line it
doesn't really matter what the actual
look is physical power we have or if you
know one person steps out of line and it
becomes known somehow and it's easy
these days you have YouTube
Instagram um well Instagram only through
VPN these days in Russia but still you
have you have ways how to make your
position known so people like us regular
people have still incredible power and
that's why it really irritates them so
much and you know we spend two years in
jail but this days it's um 25 years a
person I know Vladimir
karura his fault was only to um say that
he disagrees with Vladimir Putin's
politics and he is against the war in
Ukraine and he went he was poisoned
several times he survived and he went to
jail for 25 years and he he was brave
enough to come back to Russia even
knowing that he might face this um
charges but he said well I haven't done
anything wrong I just said what I what I
thought was right and he's um hopefully
he's not going to have to serve this
time because uh I like we all hope that
Putin is not going to last
forever um you know even though these
days we have some longevity methods and
the guy is only 70 something years old
so I'm I used to be very optimistic
these days I feel like baby I know stem
STS are keeping them in their cells and
now there's this new medication that can
um increase um the lifespan of dogs did
you see that article wait I saw only the
headline is how real is it cuz I don't
want to get too hope up well I follow
this allergist who I really trust on Tik
Tok oh I would love to follow an
allergist oh my God he's the best um
I'll send you the link but he talked
about it so I was like I feel like he's
a reliable source um Nadia I I I come
from a country cheers you're Red Bull
Annie I'm so excited we have the same
drink I come from a country where like
the people that voted our last leader in
there are some that believe he was the
guy who discovered Michael Jordan and
this was part of the propaganda machine
that basically got him elected like they
were like oh you know about this Annie
yeah youve told that told you told I
don't even remember sorry no Annie
wasn't there for this but basically um
the the story about our now our sitting
president the Philippines is that he was
in North Carolina and then he saw a
black kid begging on the street and cuz
this is his origin story Michael
Jordan and then he helped the kid like
like I don't know I don't know if he
bathed bathe him gave him clothes gave
him money and like basically helped him
out of the streets and they like that
kid grew up to be Michael Jordan and
people like ran with this like they
genuinely believed because Michael
Jordan is like the freaking of the
Philippines right and so they were like
this this story is going to land with
Filipinos and it did what a strangely
specific but weirdly perfect lie yeah
like but it's so
googleable yeah but I mean people aren't
looking for that are the truth people
aren't looking for the truth they're
they're looking for things that confirm
the biases in their mind and they're
like if this is what he could do there
what could do country look at the B oh I
know if people were looking for truth
that book would not hold really for
thousands of years so
Fantastical I know and just the
boldfaced like just lying about such
ridiculous things and then people just
eat it's like the wild part is just the
people believing it it's not it's like
lie go ahead but the fact that people
are pulling them off as the place that's
so crazy yeah how long do you think a
show like ours would have lasted in
Russia well if I were to appear in your
studio I think we all would be in um in
detention Cent by now okay so that
scares me a little bit but you also are
a little jealous of people that get to
go to prison you're our second prisoner
that we've not not who's the first one
Amanda Knox Amanda Knox it was she was
an Italian prison let me think of the
pasta was like was the food good which
we will be getting into those questions
but I'm not a big Russian Cuisine girl
I'm I am part Russian and I don't like
the food I don't like any food of my own
Heritage mhm you don't eat um I don't
eat a lot of Russian food well I'm vegan
for a year so oh
yeah you know can maybe drink vka and
eat pickles that's much now when you're
in prison you're like such hot girl
diet yeah that is vodan pickles now does
Russian prison hold up your vegan diet
for you no I've been vegan just for a
year okay and so no when I was in jail
oh I mean the the food was um not ideal
not ideal um especially when I ended up
in penal colony cuz like there
difference between jail and prison um
jail pre-trial detention then prison
when where you serve your time so in
Russia it would be jail um and penal
colony like very Gulag type oh [__] it's
Barracks 100 people living under the
same roof and sharing three toilets you
know do they put you to work they
actually make you have to work what was
your um I was sewing police uniforms oh
oh okay yeah and you put a couple pins
in there leave them in um just notes
yeah notes saying taking notes but um
yeah I didn't I didn't learn how to
tailor um so I don't really know how to
create a costume if I want to which is
um a big bummer because I I spent two
years in jail learning how to saw but
because it's a this Forest approach to
you know like one one person makes just
one little detail so that's all I know
how to attach um Pockets to cop pens
M did um growing up did you guys have to
learn how to sew no no it was part of
our requirement we called it
heyle where we had to learn um the
different we had a running Stitch cross
stitch um I'm sure they tried to teach
me in second grade they tried to teach
me to read too I actually I embroidered
into a pair of sweatpants slave for you
on the butt cuz when the Britney song
came out so um you may have been in
prison at that moment when Esra was
sewing her the ass on her pants wait so
you embroidered um was it a gift or did
you buy it yourself no it was like H
MAAC we had like they gave you like your
own M like own moment yeah we all made
stuff in homech yeah they made us just
we had pillows we could pick from like
you could make like an ice cream cone or
a a gumball machine I made the gumball
machine but I I like to my Approach was
very punk rock to school yeah I said
you're not going to teach me [__] A I'll
learn nothing I'm you showed them didn't
I show them just barely scraping by with
very minimal knowledge how did you make
it how did I make it just on on charm
and vim and
vigor I just had the heart for it I just
said don't kill me let me live I think
it's a better approach yeah I was a nerd
I was an O over ofer but it's not it not
really both we both end up in trouble
with the law so
yeah but yeah now now I have a daughter
and I actually like when she doesn't
treat school that seriously I hope that
her teachers does not do not watch this
but I think it teaches you how to be a
people pleaser if you Tre school too
seriously and I know some people for for
who it was great I guess but for the
most part know I had to really train
myself and relearn that's where
performance art really came in very
handy but I think you know like all the
like I probably would be much more
balanced person if I were just a little
bit more laidback when when I was in
school yeah when you um did you notice a
difference between like your thoughts
and your ideas um before you had a kid
and um after did it change you in any
way like how you um went about your art
how you went about like your activism
like were you worried at all for like
you know now that you had this like life
that you like care for it did change it
made me much stronger as a feminist mhm
and I guess stronger as a person too um
before having a kid
I I spoke with um random person I met
when I was traveling by H hiking I was
quite adventurous but that's what I'm
saying like I I would be much more
balanced if I were laid back in school I
wouldn't have to do like all this crazy
stuff later to yeah to just I mean to
balance I guess so I went on um H hike
when I was 17 um H hiking trip around
Spain and it was just me and like guys
were trying to [__] me but I was just
like what I don't have vagina don't
don't talk to me like this so Weir wait
I love that I don't have a vagina is
what I'll be saying from here on that's
all I know how to say in Spanish by the
way I
Sayang I say no
tang and I show my side pipe I go
CH I love this one I got Mir
Mir I was dating a guy from Argentina so
I know the phrase does your daughter
think that you're this badass like
feminist late or do she just like you're
my mom and yeah we don't have that thing
um like embarrassment I think it's just
um the difference between Generations is
not as big like we're literally just one
generation apart but very very very
close to each other I gave birth when I
was 18 so um you know like we listen to
the same music wear the same stuff we
have the same wardrobe and oh my God I'm
doing this all wrong you're younger than
me I don't want to hear it it's you're
not allowed to have these feelings you
know I will say this though Stella to
your um to your question I grew up with
women who were always very vocal about
sex cuz like in the Philippines like you
know sex talk is very taboo like
outwardly in public very taboo but
amongst each other we're like the
horniest like gaggle of [__] like
everything is about your nipples and
your lips and everything right so I grew
up with my aunties crude behavior and my
mom like comparing nipples in front of
me talking about their lovers and I was
never embarrassed always like I felt so
educated about like certain things and
Freer maybe about my body um much like I
think they're it's only
advantageous when like you have women in
your family kind of Express themselves
sexually especially if it's in a
positive way yeah you know like okay so
my sister's parenting Style
which is I reserve the right to judge
hers and that's the only one I'll ever
judge I no no no other parenting judging
is allowed but like she's so open with
her kids like there's no adult
conversations there's no like they're
included in everything and for a while I
was like this is crazy but now I'm like
wait I think that's exactly how I was
raised and then I saw gwenth palro
talking about how she like gave her kids
more responsibility like earlier than
they were probably ready and I think now
I've switched I'm like on my sister's
side I don't know is that like are you
protective of her or do you include her
in kind of everything that's going on
since you guys are so close in age I
include her um but I think more people
than we think do the same thing so was I
just learned recently that um Mike
Johnson um I think it was him right like
isn't he the guy who has porn um
application U like you know like
whenever you use porn uh somebody else
in your family gets a notification about
your porn is oh [__] and so that guy um
shared it with his son who's 17 yeah and
like so those people claim to be
conservative right so I'm saying that
actually people on the different side
side of the political and ethical
spectrum they do that as well and I
think that's like way too much I would
CU I wouldn't want my daughter to know
about my porn use personally oh my God I
think it's over I mean like it's it's
exactly what you say it I guess just
like putting way too much pressure on
just a a young mind because like she
doesn't have to think about my porn use
and if I I have to be in control if I
don't want to use porn I have to be in
control of my own impulses and emotions
and done put my kid um as my gardan well
okay so two things that that just REM so
my dad when we were growing up he got my
brothers because my brothers were buying
it was when there were just magazines
and stuff and there were videos but
there there wasn't we didn't the
internet wasn't really around so my
brothers were buying like like dirty
magazines from the kids in the
neighborhood they're like burying them
in the they would go pick them up at the
Park and stuff but it's like they're
like sticky pre-used and they're
probably I think they were like I think
they were like more spread ones you know
they were like a little more graphic so
my dad when he found out about that he
got a
Playboy um subscription and then they
just had them in my dad's office and
they could go get them and I would go
get them and look them be like that's
not what I look
like that's okay I don't think I'm on my
way to that but okay my mom doesn't look
like that either wa when was the first
how old were you when you were like I
don't like look like the girls in the
magazine it was pretty early on well I
was always stuff my mom had uh really
small boobs because she had a she had a
tumor in her pituitary GL she had
pituitary adoma so my mom always talked
about like she didn't get her period
till she was like 30 like she was not so
when she had small boobs I thought like
oh that's because of her she's just got
a thing so I would like put socks in my
training bra i' be like I'm gonna have
these big ass boobs I can't wait and
then they never came in and I was like
oh and so you I realized probably around
16 like they weren't going to Blossom
and we'd had those nudie mags for a long
time so I mean it was just but I also
didn't know about really fake boobs or
anything either I didn't know what was I
was the opposite of you because my mom
is flatchested and so I was I would pray
for boobs I was like I'm never going to
get them and then it kind of and then
they you know for me it was a very like
it was a gamble right cuz I'm half
Filipino half white and I would always
be like well what direction will my
[__] go like will it go Filipino will
it go white will it go sideways are we
making a sideways Asian vagina joke and
it went the Filipino route like I have a
I'm proud of the fact that I have a
brown [__] right and I you not need to
be Filipino for that I mean no but I
mean like it that is a good point that
is a good point but like I looked at you
know I grew up with a NY mom my mom was
always like naked around us right and I
was like oh my [__] looks like hers and
I was like oh that's the route it went
but you know it's when you're a half kid
half half of something you're you always
do Wonder like what traits What genetic
expression what if you just had one lip
though that was Asian and one that
honestly I think that's what it is you
would have a big only fans career if so
that's like seems valuable has the rise
of amateur porn like homemade porn only
fans like uh benefited or like uh kind
of ruined your like how has has it
affected your self-esteem oh it's helped
a ton a ton now I see girls with
hemorrhoids and like everything and I'm
like oh normal bodies no but you it's
like every one I mean look like you're
pregnant like that's this going to be
really helpful for you soon to see all
the I don't understand this like cuz I'm
the most sorry I'm very constipated my
whole life but you guys are the ones
with hemorrhoids and I I I don't have
hemorrhoids Oh I thought you guys bonded
over that I'll be the one okay I'll I'll
be the Hemorrhoid girl no we me the
Hemorrhoid over here I'm actually
dressed as a hemorrhoid not a bar no we
bonded over [__] blood Esther we we
used to both have we friends because I
saw on an episode of her other podcast
that um when you your poop is like black
it means there's like blood in your
intestines and so I was going through
some
struggles I was enjoying a little
ketamine too much and uh I gave myself a
nice little ulcer yeah and that's what I
learned all right but no hemorrhoids but
as a um Annie what can you tell us about
external hemorrhoids I had
a I had a
what this she's already been a prison
twice like actually have I have a weird
question that's like not about the shape
of my hemorrhoids no actually it is no
like because we're just talking about
what we saw and how it didn't make us
feel good about ourselves I have like
very specifically grew up with a lot of
severe self-hatred because I had dark
hair and pale skin which today I'm like
that's so crazy but like growing up I
was like I'm not blonde I'm not tan I'm
ugly that's obvious and you are so
beautiful and have dark hair and pale
skin did you have any of that that I had
or no thank you
um no not really um no um I I did not
think much about my appearance cuz as I
mentioned before I was super nerd so I
was mostly um I wasn't really social
well I'm still not really but a little
bit more just because I'm an activist so
it makes sense for me to go see people
sometimes but when I was a kid I had
zero wish or reason to go see anyone so
I didn't really get any feedback you had
no awareness of your of looks and then
you were just like oh I'm pretty they
didn't show you they didn't show you um
Snow White the most beautiful fair skin
I remember my mom bringing that up and
being like look at Snow White she she's
pale and has dark hair and that's a like
a princess and I was like she's ugly
it's so the opposite I grew up in a
country that only that prefers like
literally all of the shops have
whitening products there is such like if
you were not light-skinned you're just
considered like ugly did you dislike
yourself no because I had lighter skin
compared to the average Filipina like
they called me mysa so they propped me
up as being prettier than someone who
was full Filipino right so it's [__]
up so I grew up being like oh she's so
pretty but my sister is very dark and
they were like you know she'd be
prettier they say some [__] up [__]
like that so depending on where you are
in the world was like really different
like Beauty standard so you would have
been a star baby over there you just
weren't in the Philippines that's all
keep hearing this I keep hearing I would
have been a star in the Philippines you
would have now we just have we hope your
daughter is we got to get her in Show
Biz
Quick the pregnancy only fans we'll see
Nadia what was your um I know you said
you were a nerd but like what was your
childhood like your family Dynamic Mom
Dad all of that my mom and dad separated
when I was five but I um I was
communicating with both of them but I
lived with my mom and then my mom picked
another
guy um who
is um so we have this phrase in Russia
um you're under heel I don't know if
there it's there is a translation for it
in English but basically when you happy
to be told what to do by a woman so he's
she's an absolute
matriarch yeah and she she wasn't she
wasn't getting that Dynamic with my dad
so they separated because didn't work
out for them I love this and yeah it's
just she's still up to this day she
would be telling him you know like
nobody asked you what your opinion right
now just close the door from from the
other side and just come when I tell you
so and he like absolutely fine with this
um and like more than that he enjoys it
well he understands this a little bit
like like
playful like almost like BDSM is Type
Thing CU you know she doesn't hate him
when he she says that and she does she
does it in a little bit in a playful way
sometimes she goes over the top but it
seems to me like he still loves it so
that's that's where I was growing up and
so for me
matriarchy was not not a construct it
was reality so like when I would get out
to say normal world that was awkward cuz
like I I saw that men wanted to play
that role and that's why I became
feminist really early on that is so
interesting I like I've really been like
I feel like the most masculine you can
be is if you are in service of the
Divine that's how I always look at it
it's like that's how I feel my fiance as
he's just like what can I do to like
help you like do your thing I mean he
saws his own stuff but there's a term in
Filipino that they use it's not is it h
he said it's so kind like more like
you're under the hill so you're
basically yeah you're existing under the
hill that's so funny in the Philippines
you call it they just say oh is is under
is he under and that's literally
everyone understands what under means it
means like means under sawasawa meanings
you were under the the woman of the
house and that's how they describe
certain men I think it needs to be like
that to an extent in my opinion because
a man like is more powerful inherently
and then if the woman is like
subservient to him all the time that's
like a little bit scary to me I don't
know yeah it's also not uncommon in my
um like certain Dynamics or matriarchal
Dynamics in the Philippines where the
husband is the bread winner but the
woman can has the money holds the money
makes the decisions how to spend the
money for the family because he cannot
be trusted almost yeah it's very Russian
at all is it yeah it's so interesting to
me we call it a country of domestic M
Hurrican domestic because they don't
hold like big post like know the woman
never was a president in Russia but but
that's very interesting to me because
it's usually maybe there's a parallel
here with having like like say for
instance like a country like the
Philippines it is so technically very
misogynistic still but that domestic
matriarchy is real the women do run [__]
but just quietly and like but the
appearance that they want to project
into the world is that still of like
this strong male like patriarchy where
it's like we don't have like women's
rights here abortion isn't allowed you
can't even divorce your husband who's
beat you but really the truth is in the
home the women run [__] they just don't
want to say that out loud it's pretty
much like that I mean it's just wonder
why why is it in this way why why is it
happening like why like man is is too
scared to admit that that's how things
are around in our countries I have like
a lot of friends who are single who are
like I just want a man to lead to take
control and I think we all have that
instinct where we kind of like oh that
sounds good but I don't think men want
to do that in America like I don't I
think men want a woman to like tell them
what's up no I think that they want to
be perceived as Leaders but they don't
want to actually lead yes want to do the
work to do it but so for me the
consensus I mean what I've come down
like what I now believe is perception is
more means a lot more to men than women
it's how they're perceive it's not what
they're actually doing um what wait did
we ever get into this discussion about
like how MA masculinity is like just a
performance like in today's world like
it's just how do you perform as I think
about that spider the spider that like
does the dance or bird so funny they
just do like these dances for the women
and then they just kill them if it's not
good enough and then they bang them if
they don't but they they just stab them
so quick they're like that dance is not
good enough they're like just putting
their like things out they're like look
at me and also I want to say like
there's nothing wrong with being a man
who identifies as masculine that wants a
woman to like take charge and Lead like
I think that's really cool and hot I'm
not like shaming it at all I think do
you think that also it's just like I
mean this could be just nature versus
nurture too cuz I don't know like how
much culture plays into it but some
people are just like alphas and I don't
know if it's like I had a very Alpha
boyfriend and it was not cuz I'm Alpha
so it was a [__] nightmare and he was
so much louder than me and cops were
always getting called and it was just
like because I just don't feel
comfortable with a man like telling me
what to do all the time and it just felt
like there was a part of me that was
like would get up and like make his
breakfast and like oh like make him
happy in the morning or whatever and
like maybe there was like a little part
of me that felt good it felt good to
like put on an apron but it was like a
[__] Halloween costume it didn't feel
like I'm like I don't want to do this in
my life like is crazy that a man was
like telling you what to do it was CRA I
I'm telling you police the building
shook it was I he still is in the
apartment I don't think he can leave CU
he's the security deposit the will not
cover what was done to that apartment he
his new girlfriend's just having to
closed like a broken the doors are
broken I can imagine there are a lot of
men who have a kink for um wanting you
to absolutely dominate them they do yeah
I'm both my main Persona my only the
fans is is a dominatrix um and I've been
enjoying only the fans so much because I
feel like
secretly like a a portion of people
who've been following Pat and who've
been supporting us they also had like
some fantasies
about me or
us um but then people are very I mean
like obviously it's weird to just come
to an activist um Instagram and just
start talking about your kinks that
would be I mean inappropriate so they
they were rightly uh ashamed of it but
then at some point I realized that I
want to give them an opportunity to
express that because I don't think there
is necessarily something shameful about
sexuality if it's consensual right if
I'm saying it's okay to express your
fantasies about me and then it just
opened up the
whole like door to um me learning so
much about people who support us and and
them learning about me and me learning
about myself in this process uh but yeah
what he said
about you I think you said the the most
the strongest man is the one who in
service to the Divine in service to the
Divine they're very much into this King
fantasy whatever way of living and I'm
Hing them to explore this part of them
because a lot of people who follow me in
regular socials and specifically and all
the fans they're they're nerds as well I
guess I'm attracting nerds to so but
they they don't really think or talk
about their sexuality but I'm like okay
you can open up to me right now you can
talk about being in service to me and
talking about your masculinity and all
the stuff you've been discussing right
now here and you know masculinity as uh
as performance femininity as performance
it's so fascinating cool me hot but like
so educational that you have just this
like mass of boys who are able to
express themselves freely without you
know the shame of it all but then really
kind of learning like what what my Kink
is shaming people's Kinks though oh that
is your I just want to just laugh and I
want to tell is that really your Kink is
that like what gets you off oh I enjoy
it so much sexually I love to just like
emasculate no maybe it's more social I
don't know I enjoy it we'll see I
haven't I haven't gotten the opportunity
to do it enough you know what I would
love not to Todd like Todd is Todd's
gold but that is a real thing is like to
humiliate someone but I like okay so
some people love to
be you know humiliating people's [__]
it's
they love it and you like I I know that
you've had um people with different
political views even want like their
Kink is to be converted by you right I
know and that was so interesting to
me God would come out be like I'm in s
I'm in in the opposite side of political
Spectrum I'm like what what does it even
mean she's like I cannot tell you much
because if that will ever become known
I'm just going to get fired from my job
but I want you to convert me where or
another person was um know working as a
pration officer and I was telling him
that in Russia no in in the United
States United States and then he told me
that uh well I told him that you know
you have to promise to me that you're
good to people you work with and
obviously you know you I have to take
his word and but but at least you know
we have this conversation so I'm like
you cannot be an [__] to people you
work with and continue coming to coming
back to my page um so he promised me
that he would be nice and he would work
on himself and he would try to spread
this word to other probation officers
and then he really loved just wearing
dick cage for me and putting the
stickers in his bot and sending me
pictures consensually I was asking him
for those pictures like this bot belongs
to Naja
that's love that so much I mean like we
might have to cut this out so we don't
you know fire up the Trolls but um there
is a part of me that every time I know
what you're going to say every time I
receive such like for instance like up I
posted a like a picture of a pie a
caramel pie for Thanksgiving and I will
get mostly like where's this pie from
but there's always like
15% where it's like [__] or something
very
agressive they put the zero so it
doesn't get hidden and my thing is like
oh that's the guy who is just so like
like bricked up for me yes like he
cannot contain his lust for me that he
has to reply to a Thanksgiving picture
and say [__] and there is a part of me
that wants to say something back like
like send me a dickpic like let's do
this like what do you want to do let's
Converse if this is the only way we're
going to get through to your [__]
incel brain then I throw me into that
experiment like let's [__] do this
let's have about because the thing is
for them for someone to be like have all
these feelings about someone they don't
know it's obviously like a projection of
like and a amalgamation of all that I
don't know if that's a real word it's
schol um thank
you got in I think you said it wrong
most again amalgamation amalgamation
amalgamation you're adding a
u because I want
any I didn't want to be narcissistic but
um but so I'm okay with not knowing
things we know we know what if I wasn't
what if I was like guys we need to stop
doing edit these
out do I think it's a very very powerful
feature and or skill of a human being
being okay with not knowing I just
recently learned about it like two years
ago before that I was just always had to
be like just make [__] up but appear
that I know things and it just makes you
makes you look more stupid but also it
got you to the place that you are you
know what I mean and then you get older
and you go like oh it's like cool I
don't know things thinking you know
everything that's repulsive my dad used
to say like true wisdom is the discovery
of your ignorance like the day you
discover how ignorant you are is the day
you've truly like stepped into your
wisdom I'm like that actually makes
sense I love waking up every day being
like I don't know jack [__] and that's
okay like it's so freeing now it's like
I'm a blank slate and you can just
inform me and then also when you realize
that every every else has like a
different perception of what's going on
and then also that your memory is like
50%
wrong that is crazy when you're like I
have been standing by the story and then
you're like adding things to the story
not even on purpose over over time to
kind of likeing fit whatever story you
have in your head I want to go back to
your only fans so like how is it set up
is that your main thing is mostly a
dominatrix I started 100% dominat Trix
and then I just uh started to explore
different parts of myself so I not 100%
dominatrixs I mean like I I play
different roles and like have a more
just vanilla side to me like definitely
not submissive like there were people
who tried to make me submissive but I'm
just 100% against it and just like I
don't feel good about it at least um on
only the fense I mean I might play it in
in like the actual bedroom but not not
on defense it's just different me yeah
and like there was a guy who was very
specific and it really rubbed me in the
wrong way he but I was like I'm a little
bit
masochistic just in um social
interactions I have it but so I've even
ended up in abusive relationships I
think because of that because I I like
this feeling of just Tak you know
there's something hurting me and I just
keep pushing the same but
so I think I was doing that with this
guy on the too he he asked me to call
him daddy first which I did which is
like not my thing but I did okay okay I
called him daddy and then he asked me to
tell him that um say I've been bad
um I've been
um you know I've been a ask I think he
asks me to arrest me and bit the [__]
out of me with his um police baton [__]
she's like I've been a bad girl and I've
been arrested for protesting against
Putin and now I'm in your power so it
was like very close to my skin it was
like way too close and especially in
like a mask he was [__] riding you
abag after two years in jail like I mean
like there are things I'm willing to
play with and their things like just not
we all have our levels of comfort do you
think Putin watches porn and do you
think he has access the only fans and
who do you think are his in his in his
top five rotation well we know that he
does not use internet so maybe he was
just porn in whatever be head he just
makes people [__] in front of him he
doesn't need porn Julius yeah but I'm
sorry like even the the person with the
most like sexual Vigor like they just
want to stay in bed like and jerk off
and get crusty in their sheet right like
that is just I'm talking like he has to
have his Lazy Boy days of being like I
don't want to call in you know a whole
sexual Brigade to perform for me today I
just want to I'm imagining him in one of
those you know those like old people um
lazy boys that like they lift you up do
you know what I'm talking about so it
helps old people stand up my grand so I
like the idea of him like jerking off
like with it half up
like the seats like holding him no when
my grandma got that after her shoulder
surgery I had so much fun playing with
it it's cute it lift it was like and
down around I mean this was it stands
you up it's like incred it hoists you
out so he doesn't have internet so he
probably doesn't um part won't be
watching yeah I don't think so um I I
really just don't even want to think
about his sexual life he's so disgusting
to me I'm don't I to me he's not even an
actual human at this point to me he's
just a person personification of evil
yeah and yeah that's a really good thing
to do when you hate someone so much you
just desexualize them like that is like
the opposite is pretty bad when you're
like I must [__] M no what I'm just
saying it's almost like like what you're
saying it's like I don't even see you as
like a living breathing sexual thing is
like the ultimate like stab in the heart
because I'm sure that's all he wants to
be perceived as is like man with like
Vigor and strength and you're like no no
no no no you didn't have a penis to me
that's fair I love I love this phrase
you don't have a penis you don't have a
penis I don't have you don't have a
penis Tango pooa Nadia do you feel you
practice BDSM a lot do you feel actually
like sexually aroused with by dominating
or do you feel like it's a form of
activism both yeah I I enjoyed sexually
as well um it's been it's been a long
way for me to to admit it I think it's
it was I was trying to put all sorts of
filters um between me and um um like me
as an artist using bgsm and me actually
enjoying it but then yeah I think I do
and it makes me
feel just more sexual I guess and um
maybe I think it really Taps into this
um my king of um needing to feel like
matrick in order to be in charge of my
sexuality cuz I was growing up really um
a sexually repressed because in Russia
we don't really talk about sex there is
been this I mean at least with the
generation of my parents so we had this
phrase in the U
USSR before I was born that we don't
have sex in the Soviet
Union meaning that we don't talk about
sex people obviously still [__] but they
we didn't talk about it so with my mom
with my dad or my stepdad never even
acknowledged like so even if people
would kisse um on a TV screen and we
watch it with my family they would be
just like you have to turn away and when
I was 14 that was [__] awkward though
in America too I remember watching stuff
with my parents like uh you're like
keegin you're like everyone's like uh
didn't you watch sex in the city with
your parents I watch sex in City my I
would like walk by and like peek and I
just was so uncomfortable well we would
watch sex city and then I remember one
time asking my mom like do you have hair
on your [__] and she was like Annie
and I was like we're watching this and
the answer is yes and obviously you do
[__] you never she's like I don't know
I was like you never checked sounds like
a hairy butth hole to me an hbh to me no
um one of my um remember when the L word
first came out the show lesbian it was a
it was a series it was a show about hot
lesbians basically they're in LA and
their relationship should given up
some but the whole every all the girls
in my family a crush on Shane remember
and so it was really uncomfortable I
remember thinking like my sister my best
friend my mom it's like we can't be
watching this stuff together guys like
our feelings are too real yeah it's like
obviously all spping wet over Shane like
this is unhealthy like we should watch
this privately on our
own okay so you've probably heard the
word micro doing oh yeah baby and if you
haven't just know that all sorts of
people are micro doing to feel healthier
and perform better yeah you know know
when it's like you have that just right
feeling in your body like you're just
feeling like a little yeah a touch
lighter a little happy in your bones
yeah you don't want to have to be like
totally hammered or totally no that's
high yeah you got live your life in the
past I have used micro doing to relieve
anxiety to feel relaxed to feel just a
little a little peppy in my Steppy you
know at work whatever after working out
it's always good too calm yourself down
a little before you sleep so your
thoughts don't take over in the night
we're not Snoop Dog here okay we can't
this our Persona is not to be the
highest we've ever been we have lives to
live we have things to do we have a baby
to raise we have things to do guys I'm
in a pants suit I have serious business
to take care of okay I have to learn to
read I have to learn to read you don't
have to no I think rebel against that
you don't have to learn to read I do
like when the author reads it out loud
to me in my ear I'm like o I feel like
I'm emasculating them read it to me man
read me your writing to learn more more
about micro doing THC go to micro do.com
and use code trash Tuesday to get free
shipping and 30% off your first order
again that's micro do.com code TR
Tuesday micro do.com code TR Tuesday for
30%
off I was growing up with a lot of very
hidden interest towards sexuality but
mean I was like a very horny
teenager but um I also never could
acknowledge that I have this
and so you know to your question I feel
like yeah is this figure of a dominatrix
that is you know they can know this um
prehistoric um images of um a fertility
goddess so she's she's my Persona of me
steing into my sexuality and admitting
that it's okay to have this feelings s
awesome when my dog was sick I was like
I am Athena of my family I was like I
don't even know what Athena means but I
was like I feel like a and I'm taking
care of my sick dog and my family is
Randy better he's better but just like
the past couple days it took so long
thank you for just not asking questions
and just eating the Banana by the way
I'm sure that was just that was random
but we do have this thing called banana
break and it's a time to reflect and be
in our feelings but we call Banana
jailbreak for
you um how Wild was it that you were so
your persona was faces covered how
excited were people when you revealed
your hot ass face probably expecting
some Ugo feminist and you guys are so
hot you're like psych I was hot the
whole
time I mean that must be an extra like
shot to the gut right like oh really
want to [__] her DN [__] they're
all well Madonna who supported us when
we were in jail she said Putin just
wanted to [__] us that's why he put us
in jail yeah or gay Madonna's always
right friend of mine says all the time I
yeah again like I don't even want to
think about he six he nothing he's
nothing yeah he's a
neuter um but do did you feel like the
women's movement in uh
2016 or 17 I can't remember when it was
do you think that we stole your
beautiful cool mas and turn them into
the most embarrassing [__] hats of all
time I cannot believe I wore that [__]
hat I wore it too it's that is one of
the most embarrassing moment like did
Trump make that like was that at us wait
who came up with a [__] hat we must
have been fooled but it had to have been
inspired by that cool yours was so cool
you guys were punk rock and I think we
turned it a little bit to um they were
just nerds like knitting no offense I
know you're a nerd knitting and it was
we were not we were not needing them we
were stealing them from supermarkets and
then cutting to we I think I think our
women's M needed more punk rock it I
think our women's movement if we had
just really modeled it after [__] Riot
and gotten the mask with the cutout eye
music maybe let's throw some music into
this the impact we would have had I
think he still can do it there still the
thing about P it's a movement and anyone
can be part of this movement now who can
join yeah before that can you oh there
you go um for people who don't know what
is [__] Riot what is it I to process
the banana in my mou okay [__] RI was
started in 2011 it was a reaction to
Vladimir Putin announcing he's going to
run for president for the I mean run for
president okay he's going to become the
president for the third time and it was
a bad sign because two times is okay I
mean like you can hate a guy but it's
it's fine it's constitutional people can
serve for two two times three time uh
third time means that he's basically
becoming an autocrat which was not cute
I wasn't big fan of uh his back then so
we started this movement and we decided
to go to the streets uh to perform gilia
sty and tell people in Russia that
protesting is indeed an option and uh
after six months of performing at
different places in Moscow the Red
Square we had a tour around a glamorous
places in Moscow because our thought was
thought process was that Moscow was very
much um into just enjoying people were
enjoying themselves which is like fine
but also you have to think a little bit
about like the future of the country so
you have to think a little bit about the
where do this money come from and so
Putin was using a lot of oil and gas
money selling feeding feeding them back
into Russia's public and it was that
kind of consensus that I'm going to be
using this um extra oil and gas money
without con um um without criticizing
Putin's regime so we decided to go to
all this glamorous places and remind
people that it's okay to use money but
also you have to think about human
rights so there was that we did um um a
series of action in public transport to
bring our message to just regular people
was that when you were kissing the
police officers no it was different it
was it was a different group thank you
really making out with the female police
officers it's so L have you seen that
Esther no that's really cool it's so
funny you can't do it to the guys they
just be
like I love you idas shirts is it I know
you look thank you this is this is an A+
look thank you I'm really the maternity
looks I'm struggling I'm trying to get
creative here this is very creative I
like it she's not pregnant from the
waist down thank you thank you I'm sorry
and I'm like this is like the first
episode where I'm realizing like sitting
for a while is hard is that that's
probably not a normal symptom I know
it's normal yeah I mean everything is
hard when you're
pregnant you even though you were 18
yeah it was so hard but you asked me a
question in the beginning I didn't
finish um answering it because um um it
was a question about like how did um how
did becoming a mother change you so I
became much stronger feminist because I
realized that I I hope that's not going
to happen with you because you're
already accomplished established person
but I was 18 right so like people would
just start projecting all sorts of stuff
on me and I didn't have like real
anything I mean I I I didn't have strong
enough identity and I guess career to be
like no wait I'm not just a mother I'm
also this and this and this and this so
suddenly at 18 I became just like this
Virgin Mary and people were just like
they were approaching me like it was a
good thing they were just oh my God
you're so cute you're just like young
virgin Mary with Jesus I'm just like
[__] I want to be a radical artist I
want to be known as a radical
performance artist and thinker and a
philosopher I'm studying philosophy in
like the best uh University in Russia
this is not what I want to be or wait
that's amazing that you did that even
though you had a baby you did all that
like you did what you set out to do you
kind of you know like we're we we're
stronger than people think we are women
but yeah I think it's it's easier
probably because you already have
something going on so you can just
simply point be just like I'm alo this
and this and this and this and I
accomplished all these beautiful things
in my life but it made me a stronger
feminist because I realized how easy for
people um is to ruce woman to being just
a mother just a maternal figure one
dimensional and even when they think
they're doing a favor to you they're
they're talking um like you're so
beautiful as a mother you're so good as
a mother but yeah I'm also a lot of
other things yeah yeah well I'm still
undecided at 40 years old so but I have
Frozen embryos I'm right there with you
but it's like I feel like so going home
for the holidays I was just home in
Philadelphia with my family and my
fiance's family and it's it's just I it
never makes the decision easier it's
like I'm always so torn when I leave the
holidays it's like my my my
mother-in-law really wants me to have
kids like as soon as possible my parents
are don't give a [__] they want me to do
whatever I want I feel like I want that
experience but I don't feel like I want
it now but you know what Annie I see it
as Choose Your Own Adventure like don't
even base your like thoughts ideas
around like what you're seeing in front
of you or how parents are with their
kids cuz like I've seen the whole
variety like I have seen like friends
who are just so entranced by Parenthood
who were like I [__] love this [__]
makes they are entertaining they make me
laugh all day and then others who are
like like like hair loss like [__]
stressed parrots right so it's like
Choose Your Own Adventure I think that
if you just like ultimately like you
made the decision to like create embryos
so I think like that's really [__]
decision yeah and I think just be easy
on yourself want to give them I just
want to surrogate and then I want to
give them up for adoption and I want
them to find me when they're
18 they are just give them to me too
close oh it's too close you don't want
to see your kid you know what one of my
girlfriends I want surprise I want to
reveal like her I want them to reveal
their face and be hot one of my
girlfriends said this and I'm like no
one has ever said it better both options
having kids and not having kids are
equally as terrifying right and I'm like
you nailed it you that's it before
pregnancy I really looked at the
negatives of it it's it's easier to see
the negatives because it's like you're
so comfortable and like your freedom and
everything and then now I've to it's
like you totally shift and now even
though pregnancy is very hard and I
don't love it I'm like in a very
positive excited place you're still
doing good though you're like handling
it it's a sacrifice yes that is true I
had a question for you um Nadia I mean
you've been in prison you know you're an
activist there's so many so much of your
life is like like high octane right like
it is scary like I'm I can't imagine
being on a [__] you know most wanted
list you know in your Elementary much
less by you know a whole [__] country
right like what what do you do to take
care of yourself like what are some
self-care um things that you've done
that you find like the most
effective my cat and
I SAA really helps and jumping a cold
pool
after you say SAA like Finnish people
say it SAA yeah here they say sauna
we're we're we're closer to Finland yeah
I'm half finish so she hates that food
too she's russan she's finish don't
bring any finished food around her don't
even know what finished food no have you
ever finished finished
food then I apologize for taking
exercising yeah
stretching what kind of exercise do you
do
um running I run a lot um damn lately I
started to do yoga I've been stretching
before but I finally got into the Grove
of just Yoga Yoga it rolls right isn't
it amazing it's pretty good it's
unbelievable and then um
weightlifting and just some some cardia
so that's one of each of us Esther she
doesn't run she walks but she's a walker
no we've done yoga together is it true
that um on your only fans you also like
rate like body parts and like penises
and stuff like that I I rate penises
yeah what is um it's funny like nobody
asks me to rate their [__] it's just
like not the I have a lot of uh
subscribers who are girls and my um
highest pairs are women mhm but um only
guys for some reason was yourest pars
are women yeah of course why does this
make so much sense when I'm on
ChatterBait my God those tokens fly like
I am a high paying client what is
ChatterBait what do you do on
ChatterBait what are we learning about K
learn a new thing about your friend you
sit next to every day I don't can I just
be clear I don't know this person I just
want everyone to know I don't know this
person it's it's a weird thing we're
very good friends I don't know a goddamn
thing about her
I would fail a newly W game with you so
hard like I would never know one of the
answers no it's um yeah no I mean like
if if if it's a what is she what is she
Esther Esther doesn't know either go on
these different rooms where honestly
it's women who are um who have a lot of
milk in their breasts and they squirt
into the camera and I pay for that it's
so so it's like cam girl
it's cam girls it's live rooms that you
can enter and sometimes what's cool
about it is that I always choose the
rooms that have like no one in it so
it's like oh there's only you me and
maybe some other weirdo here and it's
like click click click click click you
get all my money today and it's I don't
know it's very I I can't even describe
it cuz I'm not necessarily in a sexual
like mindset it's more like like you
deserve this [__] like get your bag I
always give homeless women so much money
cuz I'm like do not suck a dick today
[__] do not suck dick today I'm always
like this is enough for one [__] take
this that is so interesting that women
are the highest payers that that
actually makes perfect sense to me yeah
when I go to strip clubs and I don't go
there often I feel like I have to spend
so much you want to I also want to hand
it to them I I just want to go like
here's a briefcase of money take it a
strip club take it take that's why he
canot bring me to strip clubs often cuz
I was just I would give all of my money
you guys on my way home last time we
recorded I did notice we are very close
to a strip club we yeah and I just want
to say like that's on I want to throw
money at your baby though also I want to
call dibs on having the first sip of
breast milk because I feel like we're
this is going to be a
fight now that you know my ChatterBait
Hobbies yes it is going to be she even
boned up about it I'm just going to do
it as a friend wait but I have tast
she's going to do it like in a creepy
creas but you have tasted breast milk
right not on purpose my friend squir
listen years ago my first friend have a
kid in college she like squirted and I
was so shocked that it comes out like
that like I thought it would come out in
one line and it got in my mouth and I
was I was so scared I was like is this
how you get pregnant it's really it's
actually so nice and mild and sweet it's
good for you yeah but um when you rate
penises is there a criteria that you
have in your head for what a on good one
is I think we all know what is it or is
the kink like they want you to consult
them yeah as if it's really it really
depends on the context on like what what
the
person wants uh CU like some of them
just like it doesn't matter how good or
bad their opinions are they just want to
be humiliated I see do you ever are they
like I want my money back CU you're like
that's a great [__] they're like give me
my money back you [__] you [__] with a
zero it's weird like um I dominatricks H
are very very nice cuz I'm generally um
I I guess as a political activist I've
seen so many people who want me dead and
like have like death threats every like
you know like as I'm sitting here I'm
pretty sure I received 100 death threats
and 100 more people telling me that I
have to commit suicide like no joking
like there are people who are um paid to
do that right right uh and so I'm all
for kindness even so I'm even dominating
with kindness and I'm pretty sure there
should
be there should be recognition that this
is special
way of dominating with kindness well I
like that because okay so there was this
there's this um male comedy podcast and
they were like talking about female
comedians like who they thought they
were hot or whatever and one of them
goes they said about me they go Annie
Letterman looks like she smokes
cigarettes and tells you have a small
dick and I was so flattered I was like
that is like so
sweet they want that but I'm not but I'm
not like mean like that like I but
that's because I have like people pleas
in my childhood you know so it's like
but I'm like why am I so flattered by
that like why am I like yeah they're
like yeah she's like mot she's like
smokes and tells you got a small dick I
was like that is it's so cool to be mean
I I really I need to go to mean lessons
yeah me too I I want to be and like in a
way it's like you know because I think
I've spent a lot of time um in my life
making weak men feel strong or or think
they're strong when they know they're
not you know like I'm like oh I'll just
no you're doing good but it's like who
does that help that doesn't help them be
stronger men and that doesn't it's just
lying it's like faking orgasms will you
make me a stronger
man this girl already is a Cheryl Crow
um when you push her out of your penis
hole is it are you scared about having
pushing a baby through a penis hole are
you kidding that's all I think about now
when you look at your penis in the
mirror you go this is a miracle I'm the
first pregnant man I just think so much
about how like I thought women and men
were equal and we just not no and also
it's like um you know you you receive a
lot of like I'm sure like just like you
said like online just harassment like as
we're sitting here you're probably
getting a hundred people just coming
after you like does it just roll off
your shoulder at this point or is there
a part of you that's like I'm going to
go through each of these people and be
like [__] you and I do that sometimes
yeah it depends um I mean you know if if
if I'm wrongly accused of something it
it really irritates me if it's just a
random person who wishes me death it's
fine I I'm used to that but like yeah if
I didn't steal something and people say
I stole it then I start to get really
worked up and that pisses me off really
can get on you can never control a
narrative it's so infuriating you put
yourself in um such like a a situation
where it's like people's eyes are always
on you a whole country's eyes are on you
often people high paying women high
paying women but like are you like what
are your thoughts around death like are
you ever afraid like are you do you see
death as something desirable yeah like
are you afraid of it ever black tell us
how go you
are I have a friend um she's an
artist uh and she's um she's in her 70s
and um she's very goth um but not I mean
not like like she wears Goss clothes she
just go in her heart and asked her are
you hopeful about the future she was
like are you kidding me I'm so glad that
I'm like most likely I'm going to be
dead in the next 10 years and I'm just
so looking forward to that and I'm
really not envying you cuz you have to
inherit this planet with old of these
problems so I would not like I don't
know what I would do if I were in your
place and I was I would be 34 I I'm Not
Afraid necessarily but like yesterday I
felt very weird and lightheaded in the
morning and then we went to get a
Christmas tree and now as we were coming
back home I um me and my partner um I I
was just like wait I feel very
lightheaded right now I think I might be
am I be poisoned with a nerve agent and
he was just like no I don't think you're
Poisoned With nerve agent I think you
just got too too much coffee and uh you
just didn't eat anything so everything
is fine but like for for 25 minutes I
was trying to listen to my body and feel
like oh is it actually just coffee or is
it shutting down my God or is it
shutting down I it's crazy they kill you
they kill you and your they kill people
that's what I'm saying it's like it's
not even your death threats are
different than ours yeah like hours just
seem so just mild and it's like I never
have to stop and consider if my
lightheadedness is you know a poison I
will say I don't want to make this about
me but I did get very lightheaded
yesterday during a colonic and I did
think I was about to pass away I thought
I was passing does it to
you I stopped her to the first procedure
really no I I like something's going to
happen wait what happened with yours
Annie did you just like your blood
pressure I was flying I've never I've
never done it right after you fly so
dehydrated and my ass was just absorbing
a lot it was just really taking in a lot
of water and and she was like whoa like
she was even impressed they shoot water
but because I was dehydrated my [__]
was like soaking up water drinking it it
was drinking my [__] was thirsty but
I I've never been like so lightheaded
and I was like uh like I was like I
think I'm going to [__] like my
intestines onto the table I'm about to
be inside out did you get a lot
out why are you so excited why you I am
you it is amazing I'm very constipated
and I just started having to do like
water enas to help things come out and
it's really awesome no it's good I'm
really happy get colonic while you're
pregnant no I won't get a colonic but
just I squeezed some water up there and
it just kind of I had to when I was
doing my egg freezing I was so I
remember that I was so constipated that
I was like my fiance was like I'm just
ordering you a CL like you can't like
can would you ever let me digitally
disimpact you
yeah for and you eser it's basically
what you do with people who've lost
their reflex like for instance like
people who are quadr they've lost their
either their mition their urination
reflex and their reflex to poo and so
what happens is it gets impacted in
there and you have to digitally kind of
like pick it out digitally mean
digitally with a digital she wants don't
you want to give her not digital media
wait what if you what if you digitally
removed my my
kaka's while she was squirting breast
milk into her mouth um who's throwing
tokens at us because I will absolutely
do this oh my god well Nadia thank you
so
much
um the best discount of any episode I
let's go out on that beautiful you're
amazing thank you so much for coming I
hope that I'm never breastfeeding in the
same room as Annie's [__] being
dispelled I can't wait till you [__] on
the table your hand I can't wait till
you give birth and poop on the table I
don't care I would be so lucky if I poop
on the table that would be such a
blessing to get it out because women are
so constipated in birth that like people
who are scared of that I'm like you're
crazy I want that I want it all out any
anyways wait before we go what does your
shirt mean oh yeah [__] oh I love
it thank you and where can people find
your only fans and all your other stuff
um can we put it in a description
absolutely check the description baby oh
I want to do a domination I have to ask
Todd I to tell Todd I to tell people
should uh see also my video It's called
sexist you can find it by pite sexist um
YouTube um yeah dominating men very
beautifully oo exciting thank you such
an inspiration and thank you guys for
listening and watching and we'll see you
next week with a brand new episode
episode that was so awwesome
[Music]